and stick in love your character Sam
says there's two types of people
hopeless romantics and realist so I'm
wondering which are you and why I've
definitely got a hopeless romantic thing
going on I do believe in love I do
believe in all the kind of the
butterflies and the excitement and all
that I do think however though that you
sometimes need to follow your mind as
well and kind of be realistic about
situations love is a very complicated
thing and sometimes your mind does need
to kick in but I don't think it should
ever really take over from where your
heart wants to lead you so there's a bit
of both but I'm Way more of a hopeless
romantic than a realist and now Josh
Boone who wrote and directed the film
give you a kind of care package didn't
he before you start my mix CD and yeah
and I went to how that helps you and
also when was the last time you made a
mixtape with someone else or made one
for you
I think just the idea that he went to
the extent to make one for each
individual cast member was so thoughtful
and it meant so much because this was a
new experience for him he's a first-time
writer director and you know this is all
new for him and this is his baby being
made into a reality and the fact that he
cared so much to make sure that all of
us felt as excited or as supported by
him as we were really supporting his
experiment and it really was an
experiment for him but um was so
meaningful and it really did help get
into the mindset of the character and I
actually still love making mix tapes or
CDs all the time and my friends that's
been something we've always done is like
if you're in the mood for something like
for my birthday my friend gave me a
workout CD which was really funny and
like a mixtape of stuff that I haven't
heard in years and it's just something
that is so sentimental but means so much
and I love that he has some of the
parallels I think in real life with your
character in the film in a way because
you've been a writer yourself maybe
she's a writer
she also exists in the same world as her
father as you write as well did those
kind of things help you get into that
character definitely the fact that she
was a writer also something that Josh
and I talked about from day one when I
was saying you know that that's
something I've always loved and known I
wanted to do and my being in the
entertainment business like my dad is
it's something that is great to be able
to relate to each other on but at the
same
I wanted to be in it and enter into it
in my own way and on my own path and
loving respecting it at miring what he's
done but also at the same time trying to
do it on my own and I think Samantha
does that in a way which is very similar
to myself and that was really quite
lovely to have a father/daughter
relationship that I felt invested in
already and Greg is such an amazing
person to play someone's dad just
because he is so giving as an actor but
also just as a human being and he's just
got those qualities that you would want
in a dad you know on-screen and and he's
he's lovely so it was really great to
have him stand in for my own dad and of
course sounds very feisty coach played a
number of feisty characters you've got
another one coming up in a film shortly
the Mortal Instruments what was it like
kicking ass in TMI and how did you
prepare for that it was so fun I love
action and I never thought that I'd be
doing stunts and movies but the training
was intense we had about three months of
physical training beforehand and then
during filming it was every single day
with the stunt department and you know
physical fitness at like 5:00 in the
morning 4:00 in the morning before work
but it was really fun because in the end
it pays off because you get to see that
we actually are fighting and the
Shadowhunter guys had a bit more
difficult than I did because I only
learned I have skills in halfway through
the movie but all of them I mean they
really kick ass and it was it was really
fun I can't wait for the sequel because
I get to do more of that oh wow and what
was it like stepping into such a world
of series and character and one that you
were a fan of yourself yeah that was a
complete honour to play a character that
I that I'd admired in the books and I
love fantasy I always have but I love
that there's a realness to this series
but Cassandra wrote but that also Harold
used in the directing of it and it's a
film or you know we're doing the sequel
as well but I think it's a series of
books that really is different than
others because it is so based in reality
that it doesn't take itself too
seriously in the fantasy world so it's a
bit more relatable to everybody and like
a day to day life what can fans expect
and do you think the the end will be as
it is in that first books it's quite
interesting
it leaves you wondering about a very
important question which I I'd you know
if you've read the books you've read the
books and you know but it's it's
something that was very difficult to
deal with in a film I think especially
when you're tipping it at the first one
I'm wondering if it's gonna be a second
one and you have to play it both ways
and it's a very sensitive topic but I
think we do so in a way that really
leaves you wanting more but at the same
time doesn't leave you completely
dumbfounded but I'm really I'm really
really excited I think the fans are
gonna be very happy I know the
expectations are set so high when there
are so many fans of the books but I
think we've we've done a really good job
of kind of balancing that
you